a total mancini hence time on his hands
so he takes a stroll through his local
market on Piazza San kuzey motto in Rome
the 27 year old has been unable to find
permanent work since graduating with a
degree in architecture after a string of
temporary jobs he's planning to become
self-employed Mancini is getting advice
about loans at a center for young
unemployed people in the city
he hopes to start his own company that
way he'll have a better chance to shape
his own future a problem Miccosukee
level the problem is that most of the
work on offer is cash in hand without
any insurance or pension coverage or
rights illegitimate I've tried out lots
of things I've worked for a road
construction company surveying road
damage for instance in the old image but
all of the jobs were underpaid sometimes
I only earned two euros seventy an hour
that's disgraceful
and all night of going up Marko guy has
made it he's deputy chairman of a
company that helps young self-employed
people and startups get established his
firm offers financial support advice and
valuable contacts
Digital magics has helped launch almost
70 small but promising enterprises
yoshiyama you thought it was we can help
these companies establish a sound basis
strengthen their teams and set them on
the path to success
don't let them visual chase guy invests
in new ideas in particular in the field
of digitization italy has a lot of
catching up to do to become
internationally competitive but
investors face considerable hurdles said
they simply figure theocracy has to be
streamlined regulations are important
but if there's too much red tape it
stifles the development of business the
tax burden also has to be reduced here
in Italy we have the highest taxes and
the EU to improve the situation for
businesses we have to reduce taxes so
that companies make bigger profits in
order to increase investment lower taxes
less bureaucracy more efficiency
italians have been hoping for that for
years with little result now they're
being asked to vote in a referendum on
constitutional change designed it said
to speed up the reform process but the
population is skeptical they lost their
confidence in politicians long ago label
CBT doc the issue is very complex no I
don't like being forced to vote yes or
no no no no me so this forum yes or no
buddy no I'm in the no camp very nah but
Cape Italy's Constitution is perfect
yeah nothing needs changing Vyasa
you little see I'll vote yes I think
it's a step in the right direction
even if it isn't perfectly us all it'll
be an improvement on the current state
of things at any rate but Santos with
the policia motor Arturo Mancini also
hopes that things will be better in the
future
nearly half of all Italians under the
age of 30 or like him currently without
gainful employment many feel forgotten
there's a lot of frustration in the
country and official LG so it's
difficult to predict what will happen in
the future for us and for me
federally Gaza I hope that things will
go well that my plans will work and that
I'll move in the right direction you
know Parrish I don't allege you said
your biggest worry of the younger
generation of my generation is that we
don't know where our place in society is
audial Meno Lamia ek Nanshan very Pro be
Punto de Rio but now at least he has a
goal and the next step is to find some
commercial space for his future company
you